hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for
anime out pro and today i will be
talking about a massive
milestone in black clover chapter
300 is here and it featured asta's
epic return to the center stage of the
story and we also saw an incredibly
emotional reunion between osta and noel
in the middle of the deadly fight
against the devil queen megicula
several characters were just killed off
austa is back megikula's magic is so
overpowered so let's get
into it if you enjoyed the black lore
content on this channel and you want us
to keep it going you know what to do
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it helps a lot with
the youtube algorithm
and if you're new to enema pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you haven't
taken the time to subscribe
yet do me a favor and make this the
video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications quick shout out to my boy
rifty beats who makes
amazing remixes of music from anime i
love his work i've actually used some of
his beats as the background music to my
videos in the past
and he recently dropped an entire lo-fi
album based on the music from hunter x
hunter
definitely check him out and show him
some love link
in the description and independent
comment finally this video will of
course contain black over manga spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned when we left off last time
gaia had just channeled all of his
remaining life force
into one ultimate lightning magic attack
and for a little while it looked like
megicula's entire body may have been
destroyed
however at the very end of the chapter
we saw
a dark winged silhouette emerging from
the smoke
which strongly implied that makikula
survived the attack
the new chapter opens with gaia's
charred and lifeless body
falling to the ground as megicula says
that this magic that is formed by
burning one's own life
was stronger than she expected megikula
praises gaia's effort
but as we all predicted mkikula is
indeed
alive and well in fact she is not
even injured it turns out that
megicula's entire body is coated with a
high speed regeneration
curse so even though she clearly took a
lot of damage she was able to just
regenerate
instantly and gaia's sacrifice had been
for nothing i have to say that the more
we learn about curse magic the more
interesting and overpowered it seems
initially i assumed that curse magic was
very limited and that its only ability
was to place curses on others
if certain conditions were met however
it turns out that no
curse magic is a lot more versatile not
only can it bypass the cliff
off it can also instantly regenerate its
users body
and not to mention decaying world and
all of its other
unique abilities curse magic is actually
very unique and
unpredictable so makikula will not be an
easy opponent to defeat
now the question is is gaia actually
dead or is he just
severely injured knowing tabata he
totally could just be injured
even though i personally think that he
should be dead after all that buildup
for his sacrifice
but since his sacrifice didn't really
amount to anything
it's possible that gaia will end up
surviving somehow because
as of right now his death made almost no
impact
on the plot which kinda sucks after
mkikula manages to regenerate
fully and with gaia completely out of
the picture it really looks like it's
all over for the good guys
reel and charlotte are helpless noelle's
spirit dive has expired
and lor pachika is still being
controlled by megicula
megikula is already in the process of
saying gg no re
but our girl noel refuses to give up
noel
powers up and gets ready to fight yet
again despite the fact that
realistically she doesn't stand a chance
at this point she seems to be trying to
activate her regular valkyrie dress form
you can tell by the tiara that this is
not her saint stage form because in that
form she has a circular crown
and a halo but one of makikula's curses
attaches itself to noel's shoulder and
back
and just kind of drains her power away i
am assuming that this curse is just an
effect of decaying world
not an actual long lasting curse like
the one that affected her mother and
loro but we'll have to wait and see
mkikula even tries to explain using cold
hard logic that no matter what noel does
now
winning this fight is impossible what is
even the point of resisting
this irrational aspect of human nature
is both fascinating
and confusing for megicula at the same
time though
megikula realizes that this is probably
why humans are occasionally capable of
generating magic beyond her expectations
humans are not always rational creatures
sometimes they kick logic to the curb
and make the impossible possible to
quote my boy kamina from gurren lagann
and this is what makes humans so
unpredictable
nevertheless megikula is confident that
no human will ever be able to defeat her
within the confines of her decaying
world
spell devils seem to be more rational
than humans because they would never
fight someone that they have no
realistic chance of defeating at least i
assume that's the devils that magikala
knows personally because we all know
that our boy liba
is just crazy enough to do it from
megicula's perspective
humans are weird creatures and they are
willing to sacrifice their very lives
for meaningless things
like ossie sacrificing her life for her
children and gaia sacrificing his life
for loro pachika
i mean those things are meaningless for
someone like megikula but they are
certainly not meaningless for the people
doing the sacrificing and just like her
mother before her
even now against all odds noel is still
refusing to give up
because of some vague and illogical idea
of hope
throughout this whole conversation with
megikula noel is fully aware that she
has no chance of winning
but that is what makes humans like noel
different from devils like megicula
even when there is no chance of winning
some humans still do what they feel that
they must
do they still do the right thing even if
it's not the most practical
or most logical thing to do noel
proclaims that the real strength of
humans
is refusing to give up and this reminds
me so much of asta's entire philosophy
not giving up is my magic over the
course of the story noel has learned
so much from asta not just in terms of
getting stronger
but also in terms of her outlook on life
honestly i love how the relationship
between noel and asta has progressed
since the beginning of the story i love
how the two of them complement each
other as characters
and my apologies to sister lily mimosa
and rebecca
but i think that astax noel is the only
ship that makes sense
at this point these two are perfect for
each other
as noel is saying all this stuff about
not giving up magikala's like okay cool
story bro but i don't have time to keep
dealing with this
so she just activates a curse magic
spell called
exploding life suddenly the curse
affecting loro begins to grow
and magika explains that as a result of
this spell loro is about to explode
and the explosion is about to kill
everyone in the spade kingdom palace
at the same time because this spell is
going to kill loro
the third sacrifice will have been
completed and megicula will be able to
manifest fully
into this world this statement by
megicula implies that vanica really is
dead
which is something we were all assuming
but it hadn't been fully confirmed yet
a desperate noel makes one final move to
try and save loro
but before she can do anything the man
the myth
the legend asta shows up he zooms past
noel on his anti-magic surfboard
also known as his demon slayer sword and
then he pulls the demon destroyer sword
out of his grimoire he then seems to
suck loro's curse
right out of her using the demon
destroyer's sword and he proceeds to
grab the unconscious loro and rescue
her from the clutches of megicula asta
has a huge smile on his face and he says
good to see you again safe and sound
noel noel looks at asta with tears in
her eyes but also with a smile on her
face
and even though she calls him bacasta
again it's obvious that she wants to
marry him
immediately the chapter ends as makikula
gives asta the most
unamused look ever because she knows
that asta
is the hope that noel was waiting for
and she can also probably sense asta's
auntie magic
and she knows it's not going to be easy
to deal with
wow what an epic and emotional reunion
between noel
and asta this was just perfect for the
milestone
chapter number 300 asta's refusal to
give up against
all odds has been his mantra since the
very beginning of the story
and now that very philosophy inspired
noel
to keep fighting long enough for asta to
arrive
this was so incredible and emotional and
although this is a serious channel that
deals with in-depth analysis
and not shipping no lx hosta forever
anyway the big question now is this did
austa's demon destroyer sword completely
suck out
loro's curse or did it just suck out
like a portion of it so as to stop the
explosion spell
because if asta could have just negated
the entire curse
then couldn't he have just done that
during the time skip
my guess is that he just took a portion
of it out but not the whole thing
because if he can negate the whole curse
in a matter of seconds
then this power would be 2op and
makikula would get wrecked in like half
a chapter
after all that build up that we've
gotten for magikala and her versatile
curse magic
i don't think that defeating her will be
that easy not even with
anti-magic and honestly it shouldn't be
easy
osta shouldn't be able to just use
anti-magic to easily destroy every
single devil
including the highest ranked devils
because that would get old
very very quickly i want to see asta
facing serious challenges
i want to see him having to come up with
brilliant new strategies and having to
rely on the help of his allies
because that makes fights a lot more fun
let me know what you guys thought of
this huge milestone chapter
chapter 300. did you love the reunion
between asta and noel
as much as i did also do you think that
gaia is dead
or is he going to end up just being
injured
finally how is this fight against
megicula going to go
down is asta just going to cut her down
using anti-magic like he's done with
multiple other devils
or is it going to be more difficult than
that let me know
down below if you enjoyed this black
clover video and you want to see more in
the future
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it helps a lot
and if you are new to anime pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting that
option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a ton of our videos even if
you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar i wanna give a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma he is
an absolute mad lad
and disciple of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones rise above
all other clans including ingrada pate
heffa
al-jatal hirokomi and water the toasted
chi the spike
emperor otaku spidey life chanel
tungsten tarkis baked buddhist cody
hebert
and monkey d quilly finally thank you
also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh the red haired raven
angel crews rathu indeora very gucci
alicia octor
bonnie parks joy and garcia techno ted
fat boy games corey mcgowan and soul ray
slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you